here's an idea escape the heat inside an
escape room
and while you're at it why not make it a
brand new flagship location that has a
vegas twist
rocky is live at the venetian in a panic
rocky
yes okay not quite in a panic but in a
panic room
welcome to the panic escape room here at
the venetian and
let me tell you the vegas twist is that
this is not your average panic room
there is a bar
with cocktails and food and fun okay of
course but now
let's come inside the panic room
entering
the casino heist this is las vegas now
so i figured this would be the perfect
one for us to feature
but welcome this is vanessa she's going
to tell us how this room works and how
this game works because if you haven't
been to an escape room it's it can get
complicated intimidating yeah it can be
intimidating right so how does it work
so it's all about having fun we really
want it's family friendly we want your
family to come in here
work together we're also great for
different companies team building events
really we're different not only because
of our bar and lounge but we also have
no locks no keys
everything is all technical you come in
press buttons see what happens it's all
one of a kind
that's so much fun especially if you
have a couple of drinks beforehand
absolutely
it might take you a little longer but of
course when you come in here it's a 45
minute experience right yes
okay so you have 45 minutes you can get
hints we're a little bit different
in that aspect you can get as many hints
as you like our goal is we want you guys
to escape we want you to have fun
i love it so let's go into the other
side of the
casino heist and show you where you can
go ahead and steal all the money
now of course this is super visual but
this is not all you can experience here
what are the other rooms you have
we also have our zombie outbreak we have
the haunted manor we have atlantis
steampunk and the wizard trials wow okay
so
you guys just opened this month yes and
people are
finally the public is welcome to come in
yes absolutely come on guys we want you
to have fun we want you to experience
our one-of-a-kind escape rooms look at
that look at our camera guys squatting
for you
you're doing great okay so let's tell
everybody where they can get tickets all
right guys so you can go to panic escape
room.com
search our las vegas location and come
on in and see us all right this is so
cool we're gonna go explore from the
other room
thanks rocky that looks like so much fun
we're gonna check back in with rocky
during the 4pm newscast